tech groups sue desantis i know
over social media bill knew it i thought
this i thought it was going to
i thought someone in florida was going
to file a lawsuit against the big tech
companies immediately instead
it's the way around you get you get a
few minutes a few days and whoever
strikes first it's basically when
if you're gonna two countries are gonna
go to war one of them gets to declare
the war and invade
and if you wait the other one's gonna
invade you so you invade first let's
let's see what we got here they say two
technology groups on thursday filed a
lawsuit in tallahassee federal court
challenging a controversial bill that
governor desantis said is aimed at
cracking down on social media censorship
but opponents argue it's an
unconstitutional infringement of free
speech
that's factually not true it's not well
it's the free speech of the corporation
right but the the issue is so we've had
an interesting conversation about this
uh the new york times for instance
if they take an article from you and
publish it it's their speech
what happens if you write the article
submit it through a
submissions portal and then they publish
it that's actually your speech even
though they chose to publish through a
submission portal does that make sense
no and that's the way it works right now
so no this does not actually stop the
corporation's free speech
of course i mean i agree with you but
that's our that's the argument that
they're making
there's it's it's a fake argument it's a
fake argument but all of this is good
you know oh right it's got to go through
the courts it's got to be fought
you know frankly the thing that needs to
happen right now is
you know you've got to get some
conservative donors
putting some money into into fighting
this in a in a in a public
in a public way let's get some c4s let's
get
people out there pushing this everybody
knows i think this is
a huge issue 501 c 3 could handle it
sure
just going after censorship in general
is a tax deductible cause
uh yeah and and and supporting some of
and supporting some of this pushback you
know even if
desantis will because it's you know as
you know it's not just one
thing on one issue you know he's doing
the the you know the
riot stuff he's doing other stuff uh
you know they're going to take him to
court for over everything yep
and it seems i mean sadly i look i loved
ron desantis i think florida is the best
state in the union right now
but unfortunately we're alone
and this has got to change i love it
here let me read this quote
americans everywhere should oppose
florida's attempt to run roughshod over
the first amendment rights of private
online businesses
says carl zabo vice president and
general counsel of net choice
by weakening the first amendment rights
of some florida weakens the first
amendment rights of all
uh-huh let me just explain something the
bill targets i think if they have to
have
like 100 million users yeah oh oh no
since when have has the left been like
but what about the ultra wealthy
and the massive multinational
corporations who's going to protect them
that's where they're at right now this
is the funniest thing i saw somebody uh
they were commenting about uh ted cruz
he made a comment about your medical
choices should be your choice and no
government should intervene
and all these leftists are like
high-fiving like oh yeah now do abortion
and i'm like that's really funny because
you can make fun of ted cruz but what
about the defected liberals who have
always been in favor of regulating
massive corporations or who have been
pro-choice the whole time and are
telling you you're insane
see they ignore people like me because
it's inconvenient it's convenient for me
to a certain degree because then i don't
get the smear pieces coming out all the
time
but yeah when i say 10 years ago we got
to regulate these massive corporations
that are that are that are stealing the
commons
and polluting our waters and colluding
with foreign interests
and then they say the same thing now i'm
still saying the same thing oh but it
benefits conservatives
so now they're not going to say anything
and then what they'll do is when a
conservative comes out they say
you just hate free speech you're you're
going to regulate these companies take
away their free speech rights
because corporations are people my
friend the hotspot of these people is
so far beyond it's so far beyond
anything
because i mean in in my mind there's
there it's very simple
is there such a thing as a public square
is it possible for a public square to be
owned
in 2021 by a private entity
yes of course yep yes of course this is
obvious
you know this is what a lot of the
libertarian types and the people you
know frankly who are taking a ton of
money from
you know from big tech are saying is
that they're denying that this is a
thing
um and the other thing is if you
you know you are allowing these
corporations to have more power than
governments yeah india well the people's
got
hungary poland the us
all these other places have gotten into
conflicts with these big tech
companies the big tech companies usually
end up winning
and this is and it's and it's and it's
uh it's crazy because they are
unaccountable to anybody i mean is this
a
and it really speaks to what this
government is
my favorite group of people in all of
this are the libertarians
who you know should be on the side of
the free speech of the individual but
instead are on the
on the side of free speech for the
massive multinational corporations and
the alarms oligarchs behind them
the reason i love it is because they
hate they hate them
mark zuckerberg facebook they hate
libertarians they despise them
they ban them and shut them down and so
you have like
there's three groups right now you've
got the the democrat
large left umbrella which includes some
leftists who
as glenn greenwald i think was glenn
greenwald who said this they're the one
group of people with the least ability
to learn
because they advocate for censorship and
then they keep getting censored
you have conservatives who are like well
we normally don't
we aren't for regulation but in this
instance we recognize the importance of
it and we must have our rights protected
and i'm like makes sense to me
and then you have libertarians who are
like we are being banned
and smeared and insulted i hope facebook
has the right to remove us
because in 20 years our ideology won't
exist anymore that's
it it's the most amazing thing the
libertarians i don't know i had a long
argument a couple years ago with this
libertarian guy
and he's like we shouldn't be telling
what these private businesses can or
can't do and i was like bro fine i don't
care
i was like i'm not i'm not i'm not lib
right i'm not in your bubble
so when you when facebook decides to
delete every single libertarian
candidate
and every single libertarian personality
which they're going to do and they do
antiwar.conference we had scott horton
in here he got
antiwar.com got censored why it's
anti-establishment they want war
they want bombs so they get banned too
and then they advocate for their own
banning it's remarkable like well they
shouldn't ban us i guess but it is a
private company
all right well in five years you won't
be a part of the conversation and i
won't have to argue with any
with you anymore so whatever right there
should also be a distinction i mean i'm
i'm not
actually for making this distinction
because i think that both of these
things
both you know the social media companies
and google
this you know and and other search
engine companies um i mean we we have
the same problem with both of them
right but the libertarians
and the phony conservatives will um
you know i mean they they will they will
say that uh
that uh you know facebook and these
social media companies
um you know that you have alternatives
you don't have to exist on them
right but as far as the search engine
goes i mean google and
google is really the the institutional
memory
of western civilization at this point
and
you you you just you take something out
of the search engine
and it's gone i often see stories pop up
from the gateway pundit
yeah and i don't like i don't i'm not a
big fan of using them for the most part
you know they have some
credibility for some writers but i'll
see a story and i'll be like okay i want
to i want to fact check this
and i'll go on google and i'll type it
in it's like doesn't it
there's a bunch of sites that are just
non-existent on google andrew yang put
it really well when he was talking about
antitrust not being the right answer
there needs to be something else when he
said how many of you want to use bing
then everyone like laughs he's like
exactly nobody's going to use bing
it's like google is the service google's
what people use but duckduckgo is
is is is moving in and it's it's it's an
opportunity to use something the problem
is
we're trying to market right that's the
thing i
i invent look at this i got a bottle of
water and i want to get this bottle of
water to as many people as possible
so you go where the people are facebook
and google have bought up the largest
spaces and they're now privately owned
public spaces
do you know what you know what a pops is
in new york or privately owned public
space
no so this is what happened with occupy
wall street
zuccotti the the where they had the
protest was privately owned
but because it was open to the public
they couldn't evict the protesters
they were allowed to protest there so i
tried explaining this people i'm like
okay check it out so so the the ultra
rich people like deutsche bank or
whatever they have these
privately owned public spaces and the
courts ruled
that you can privately own them but as
long as you welcome the public in
you can't shut down first amendment
activity so occupy wall street was
allowed to stay so long as they like
what's the benefit of owning them then
so they buy property for the property
value
but then what do you do with it they
turn it into a public space
and just let it be a park or something
there's probably some right off there
somewhere some city boundaries i'm sure
there's some right off there but
regardless i don't know exactly other
than if you're open to the public then
first amendment rights apply to you
not to them right and so now you have
twitter it is a public space a public
forum it's already been ruled the public
forum in the past although that
did it overturned by the supreme court
people go there to speak
a private corporation owns it they
should not have the right to shut down
the speech of an individual if we're to
operate on the assumption that this is a
violation
of twitter's free speech rights
then you're suggesting that twitter is
speaking for us
like when i tweet with my face next to
my words you're saying
twitter is being compelled to speak no
it is it's a utility
it's a platform everyone knows twitter
didn't say that
so what's the excuse that's it it's just
a lie
because they know right now the
democrats are like look these people who
run these companies are
are on our side so we'll just agree with
them conservatives
they're getting wiped out and i i think
that was a huge contributing factor to
trump losing in
2020 i'm finding it's a very different
situation to walk into twitter's
one of their buildings and start saying
what you think and then getting
arrested or taken out by their public
private security that's
probably building yeah it's private
building but when you use a service
online
it's not a private building anymore so
their right to censor you and stop you
seems to end at the door of their
headquarters or of their
of their owned property so i that's kind
of the way i'm looking at it
you know if you set up your your
business in walmart
walmart can shut you down at will but if
you have a business
on youtube you're not in youtube's
building anymore you're not right
the the big problem i think is
for one people need to sue more
conservatives should have been suing and
you know what really annoys me as i hear
from all these conservative lawyers
you can't because you're going to lose
because of this precedent i don't care
just sue just sue just
james o'keefe look at that guy yes he's
like
fires his missiles you know he just goes
for it
and then he actually ends up winning
defeating a motion to dismiss in the new
york times case
everyone said it can't be done until he
did it
too many too many people aren't pushing
back
they're getting censored they don't sue
a lot of people soon they lose but good
for them for at least trying
set precedent get better arguments
i mean all of this too is like um
you know they're they're trying to
they're trying whatever arguments that
they can come up with
because what they really want to do
is they really want to control the flow
of information
and they are un their world view has
been
rocked to its core by trump's victory
yeah and by the fact that there is stuff
out there online that they don't
like they thought they would be ushering
in a new era
of online um you know woke you know new
consciousness where everything
they didn't see that that you know there
would be an underbelly
i mean the underbelly is us you know you
know i think they didn't see it
i grew up online i've had the internet
as long as i can remember my family at
comp you serve on dos or whatever
yes then we had compuserve on windows
and then we had aol
so i've been in the chat rooms and i
have been exposed to the nastiness that
is the internet my whole life and i knew
the trolls and the hackers and the memes
so growing up i'm like welcome to the
internet but a lot of these people
they probably did not have the internet
at a young age that i
a lot of people i went to school with
didn't have computers so it was a time
when
i'm a little kid i have a windows 3.1
machine not everybody had a computer in
their house
they weren't using aol not only that if
the parents were they're not letting
their kids go in a chat room
and hear them you see nasty adult stuff
so what happens is these millennials
they grow up and it's not until their
teens they actually get on the internet
and they're in more safe environments
with more restrictions now they're
adults
and they're oh no people are saying mean
things online how can this be
and interestingly you know mark
zuckerberg and jack dorsey
have decided to side with that faction
why it's really simple
take conservative take a liberal put
them in a room and then yell
a a curse word guess who's gonna care
guess who's gonna scream
yeah yeah and so if you're running a
business and you're selling donuts
and then you have a conservative and a
liberal there and one of your employees
stubs his toe and screams ah
f guess which one's going to complain so
are they going to do in any way anyway
pander to the ideology of the
conservative who didn't care someone
blurted out a cuss word
or are they going to go to the karen and
be like but that's 1.0
i think what you're describing is kind
of 1.0 at 2.0 where we're at or whatever
whatever number we're at
um you've got 80
of the company let's say from middle
management on down
that is totally woke that is going to
revolt if you don't do anything exactly
so you know so if you're running the
company i mean i i know people who
or heard of people who um
you know feel like they're not in
control of their own company
that's kind of sad it is kind of sad
it's you know once you let it grow to be
too big and you know what
this don't hire woke don't hire well
don't hire woke
if if you're hiring woke then you don't
know the game
never get invested don't take
investments if you don't need them right
don't take investments man
so you look at like the intercept with
glenn greenwald yeah well go broke yeah
glenn greenwald have to resign from his
own company he had no control over it
he created a monster and now it's just
rampaging around
it's a bummer i mean good for him for
speaking out against it but
he made he made this machine of course
he has no control over no and and they
won i mean he's
he's doing great work outside of you
know outside of that
that uh and they've got his funding that
organization but but yeah right
i mean how many years did he spend how
many years did he spend putting his
credibility on the line
asking for the money the interceptor
right now is a skin suit with some kind
of skin walker inside of it
and it's like you know it's like that
girl from men in black yeah you know
that
you know yeah when the bug alien is in
the edgar suit
rock
that's that's what it is the new york
times the same way just keeps happening
and uh yeah and look i mean they're
they're like you know digital hessians
for antifa too
because they'll go and they'll you know
they'll serve the purpose of marking the
target
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.comcast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you